[Music]
in zero-gravity hacking news submitted
by Mary from P and W I a NASA astronaut
is being accused of hacking her
ex-wife's bank account from space that's
a really good boot her ex wife
yeah ex wife's a big pop from space damn
it
Wi-Fi is good out there do you even have
an IP address out there maybe it's
untraceable
oh you know the IP address maybe I oh
you know because they find out oh [ __ ]
the International Space Center
I wonder what their laptops look oh yes
I don't know I was picturing their out
of state I mean out of state out of like
out in the universe out of out of world
experience oh she's not in the station
that's like here on earth no no they're
saying this could be this first-ever a
space crime no way
that [ __ ] was out-of-this-world base
crying he's got to be other space I've
seen a bunch of alien movies what the
[ __ ] was that well I'm gonna go back on
that joke I like it thanks all right so
I'll be here all day do you guys
remember back when we talked about what
you said I'll be here all day like
that's not gonna be a good good show all
right do you guys remember a few months
ago we talked about how there was gonna
be the first all-female space walk but
then we it Desai's cuz they couldn't
find the right thing to wear exactly
because they drive well because there
wasn't another female suit so someone
asked them like what do you guys want to
eat and then all the females couldn't
decide either so like yeah it's pretty
tough wow sounds like you want to get
divorced
what conclusion is hot in here
no sister feel like they're all like
they're all try to discuss what they
want to eat and they couldn't make up in
mind and just took forever well anyway
it was because of the space so then the
woman that was supposed to take that
spot and then she didn't her name is
Anne McCain and she's the crime doer
fall camp [ __ ] she's doing being a cure
[Music]
yeah so heard a strange spouse summer
filed a complaint with the Federal Trade
Commission saying that we didn't Lesbos
yes okay this is what they look like
where were you
that's all I was like her wife her why
ex-wife okay yeah so an in summer right
so they are in the middle of a divorce
and that's when an was it she was up in
space and she logged in to summers Bank
and so Anne is saying that that was just
something that she had already been
doing and their relationship is to like
check up on the finances and make sure
that there's enough money for four
summers son who Ann has also raised and
so she was just trying to make sure that
there was enough money for the family
really yeah would you look at our
finances and like we got mine yeah we're
already divorced and that's her kid now
you don't mean yes I helped and raising
but if I'm getting a divorce
like you kind of have to start just kind
of separating [ __ ] and you're not gonna
go into her account
oh yeah but it's a good excuse gia it is
a good excuse but apparently not cuz
she's in trouble
why cuz once your divorce and you sign
the paper if you go into the account
it's bad it's illegal no okay so they
they're in the middle of the door so
they haven't got completely divorced yet
they so summer is saying well you know
we're already separating she has no
right to get into my account but then
Ann is saying well hold on I was never
notified I couldn't login and you could
have changed her password but you didn't
and that's why I was able to log in
because the way summer found out it was
because Ann was asking questions about
finances like oh did you get a new car
or something like that so like pretty
much letting summer know that
you have still been chicken at herby did
they have a prenup I don't know but
she's not taking money out is she's not
she there's no moving nothing
how is that hacking because if you
always had access to it exactly you have
the passport in media yeah I would want
to see if my soon-to-be ex spouse is
like spending all our money so that when
we actually finalize a divorce like when
it splits 50/50 then I don't get
anything because they spent all the
money so I would eat me $30,000 at the
strip club I'm a you [ __ ] that was
supposed to be my money or you're just
like in space totally removed from like
the rest of society and yeah it's like
missing this moment so you're like this
is one of the ways I can catch up on you
yeah that's true you could trace
everything they do let me just check
your bank accounts it's one of the
things on the list oh you ate at a Greek
restaurant with who the amount told us
to to people that's what happened to me
one time because I check our finances I
run everything and there was like this
tab at a Mexican restaurant for like
$130 and I was like who the [ __ ] did you
go to dinner with or whatever and he's
like it was just me drinking margaritas
but my so many margaritas that's what
they are trying to avoid traffic so I
was drinking margaritas because I'm like
there's no he's there's no person he's
out there with that sounds like
something he would do that's cute that's
so fun but yeah so back to this couple
here so they're saying that they have
had issues in the past and so they so
summer and her family are saying that an
is coming up with that excuse because
she's trying to win custody of summers
son who she had tried to file for
custody when they were still married but
summer didn't want that she's trying to
steal her biological son we're not steal
that just be a guardian a legal guardian
of the kid they were raising them to
raising them - yeah she just wants
custody - how long or like she was
trying to adopt the child yeah
we're like what does summer do because
we no one's an astronaut and that's kind
of like pretty bad ask one to uh what
was it she worked in the government
somehow
oh she was an Air Force intelligence
officer
that's pretty so she's like if you're
gonna hack at least do it more
secretively right
she's like CIA yeah yeah yeah cuz the
way she found out was like okay and was
bringing things up there were like hold
on are you looking at me bank account so
then summer went to her bank and got the
the login IP addresses from whoever's
into space she looked it up and one of
them was registered to NASA and that's
how they pinned it on her and then they
figured out that that was the one from
the International Space Station IP so
it's an extraterrestrial banker my
extraterrestrial crime [ __ ] I mean this
this sounds like a nasty divorce cuz uh
she oh she had an essay before semester
oh gee all she had to do is be like hey
don't log into my account and then go
back and change your [ __ ] password
but this is more dirt yeah because then
that's the nasty [ __ ] divorce now
summer has some [ __ ] to the urine can
see NASA pee yeah to use against and
yeah they're just both that's all me you
know that's what they say about highly
intelligent women they'll hack you from
space you're gonna they say that it's
NASA T and it's some nasty bastard Oh
NASA T give me the team hmm oh yeah so
they also mentioned here how Ann had
posted on her Twitter account some
official NASA photos that have now been
deleted but it was of summer's Sun so it
was a and and summer Sam and in summer
Sun they were in one photo together and
she captioned it with the hardest part
about training for space is the
four-year-old I have to leave behind
every time I walk out the door and so
what the heartstrings right there and
then so they're saying that the social
media attention aggravated
summer even more because they didn't she
didn't want and to have a claim to be
the mother of her child how old was the
kid when they first got married and like
how long has she been raising him I'm
not sure cuz that would be really hard
if like it was like a newborn and no I
do know that they do mention that he was
born before they got together yeah but I
don't know everybody is trying to keep a
kid yeah so sad yeah that's sad when
kids are involved look at the kids they
pick a mom you got one mom yeah just
like a lot of us he's had the kid in the
middle a fair way is have the two ladies
on the side and then have the kid in the
middle and see which one he goes to yeah
I think the rule should be if you came
out of my [ __ ] then I'm good to keep
you where I don't know that's consistent
across the board
oh that's true I mean like not in all
cases when there's abuse and drugs yeah
like that but between like - yeah yeah
let's it's a parameter this is getting
muddy got a you got a [ __ ] what I don't
know what I'm always saying I don't know
because if you were me for nine months
you're mine there's so many layers are
you gonna go out of this world you know
if I was the judge I'd be like you NASA
[ __ ] you're always in space you have no
time to [ __ ] mother this child so let
homegirl handle and then when you come
back from space yeah you got the kid
maybe there's like international Ike
International or interdimensional laws
you know I mean like the same laws on
earth don't govern the same like space
laws you know well maybe they need to
build a daycare center on the spaceship
yup please bring the kid with you and
the kids just like floating around to
you it's crazy that she went all the way
out there and she still couldn't give
her ex space
[Applause]
that's good that's good oh that was good
thank you oh we should have ended the
video right there that was perfect
we just won again there's another one
like little thing that they mention is
that when summer filed for divorce she
claimed that an assaulted her so this is
a nasty divorce but then and said oh no
way I think I read that wrong wait
oh no sorry I read that wrong so when
summer filed for divorce from an and
accused summer of assault and that's
something that summer denies and says
that that's part of Anne's way you get
control of the child so this whole thing
is really missing damn and acity from
lovers to enemies Nessa D that's an
asset E Wow it's like she was suffocated
or something yeah right yeah maybe she
needed space yeah
[Music]
[Music]